ten pour le passage du millénaire
beaubourg a fait peau neuve le centre
national georges pompidou ré ouvrira
samedi prochain 1er janvier donc après
27 mois de travaux
coût de l'opération 886 millions de
francs reportage daniel wolfromm et
michel levasseur
le forum de beaubourg tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui
le trou central a disparu ou presque la
signalétique a été entièrement revue
pour faciliter la circulation vers la
bibliothèque les expositions ou le musée
d'art moderne
voici celui qui a géré les travaux
pendant deux ans et demi un chantier
gigantesque de 576 millions de francs
l'accès au centre pompidou devient donc
payant pour tout le monde
fini les visites gratuites des terrasses
en empruntant l'escalier mécanique et
payants comme partout fait l'accès aux
activités culturelles
le musée l'exposition le prix de ses
activités par contre lui puisque l'accès
aux musées tue par exemple 4 ans
comprend entrée du musée d'art moderne
il a été agrandi pour accueillir 600
heures supplémentaires un parcours
chronologique depuis le début du siècle
avec les premiers chef-d'oeuvre de l'art
moderne
jusqu'aux dernières créations
contemporaines
le musée change également parce qu'ils
s'ouvrent qu'il respire davantage sur la
ville
il ya trois terrasses au total au musée
ont fait l'objet là aussi d'une
reconfiguration totale comme partout
dans le bâtiment on retrouve cette
notion de respiration avec la victime
c'est que nous sommes transparence
totale sur la ville où qu'on soit la
bibliothèque publique a pris la place de
l'administration partie le jir ailleurs
chacun des deux mille lecteurs
travaillera ainsi de plain pied avec le
quartier le centre beaubourg
miraculeusement épargnée par la tempête
est prêt à accueillir son public
ouverture des portes samedi 1er janvier
à 11 heures du matin